لانا يبدو أن هذا هو الأحدث في الهجمات
المستمرة والمهمة جدًا
التي تشنها روسيا
ضد الولايات المتحدة ، غالبًا ما نتحدث
عن هجمات روسيا
في سياق الانتخابات ، لكن من
المهم ملاحظة أن تلك الهجمات
تتجاوز كثيرًا أن
هناك هجمات منتظمة متسقة من قبل
روسيا ضد
الشبكات الحكومية ضد الشبكات الخاصة ،
ما نعرفه عن هذا الهجوم
هو أن وزارة التجارة
أكدت حدوث خرق للبيانات
في أحد مكاتبها
، كما أفاد موقع واشنطن
أن
وزارة الخزانة كانت مستهدفة أيضًا
ولم تعلق الخزانة علينا ولكن
قالت وزارة التجارة إنهم
طلبوا من مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي والذراع السيبراني لوزارة الأمن الداخلي المعروف باسم Cisa للتحقيق في Sisa ،
كما أكدوا الخرق في
بيانهم
، وقالوا إنه كان هناك
نشاط تم اكتشافه مؤخرًا على
الشبكات
الحكومية وأنهم عرضوا ما قاموا به
اتصل بالمساعدة الفنية
الآن ، يجب أن نلاحظ أن هذا يأتي بعد
ano  هناك هجوم كبير
يُشتبه في قيام روسيا بتنفيذه ضد شركة
أمن إلكتروني عالمية معروفة جدًا
تسمى
fireeye حيث دخل الممثلون
وسرقوا بعض أدوات القرصنة الخاصة بهم ،
قال أحد المصادر إن المشتبه به الرئيسي
هو روسيا في هذا
الموقف وواشنطن.  تشير الرسالة إلى
أن هذا الممثل نفسه المعروف باسم apt
29 هو أيضًا وراء هذا الاستهداف
لقسم التجارة أه ووزارة الخزانة
الآن يجب أن نلاحظ أن
مدير CISA الذي تم فصله مؤخرًا من ذلك الذراع السيبراني اسمه
كريس كريبس تم فصله من قبل
الرئيس
بعد  وصف الانتخابات الأمريكية بأنها
الأكثر أمانًا والأكثر أمانًا
في التاريخ الأمريكي ، فقد قام بتغريده للتو
حول هذا الأمر ، كما
وصف الهجوم اليوم بأنه اختراق واسع النطاق إلى حد كبير
، ويواصل أيضًا القول إن هذا الشيء
لا يزال مبكرًا ، وأظن أنه
دعونا ندع المحترفين يعملون عليه
الإيجابيات يقصد بها زملائه السابقين في sisa
الذين يقول إنهم أكثر من مجهزين
للتعامل معها
أه لكن روسيا أه آنا هذا تذكير
أه بأن القرصنة الروسية  rs موهوبون للغاية
فهم نشيطون للغاية ويقومون
بأكثر
من مجرد مهاجمة انتخاباتنا